so it's half past eleven Saturday nights
I'm home alone and you already know
what's going down and I'm playing roller
coaster [ __ ] three and I'm making a
tutorial for you goings
right so by the way I just want to get
this out there this I'm actually
commentating over a pre-recorded footage
right now because I messed up the sound
settings probably in fraps and stuff
happened and it wasn't happening fun
times
neither was was there I see t3 crushing
by the way so I'm basically I got to
tell all the things that I'm doing right
here and give my amazing train of
thought away and the great great stream
of consciousness that I always have and
start rambling and stuff like that so
basically connectors connectors again
connectors everywhere but in this case
I'm just going to use the same as for
the big whatever you call those things
the big smooth gradual drops that I had
in the beginning and the first drop I
usually take a gentle too steep
connector for that part and then for the
upper parts use a gentle connector
that's usually not even a steep
connector for small hills like these I
don't know why but the next thing is the
mid-course brake run also refer to as
the MCB are just so you know some people
tend to call things the MCB are and
confusion usually arises but anyway
speaking of the MCB are real be and I'm
sit-downs in real life they have like
this the spline goes underneath the
location where it usually goes
now this is hard to explain but you can
see me in roller coaster tycoon 3
placing that little block right there
now the way that works is in real life
like I say PNM's have the spline this
the spine this plane it's an entirely
different thing the spine running
underneath the location where it usually
goes for the mid-course brake runs for
their brakes actually have a position to
place them and have like the motors and
stuff like that now rollercoaster tycoon
3 doesn't have that so you have to edit
yourself by the way you see that you see
that brake thing intersecting with top
of the track right there you don't want
that to happen you really need the and
piece
the end of the straight section not
where it goes to the gentle Saxon
section because otherwise it's going to
intersect and look kind of ugly and yeah
that's basically the story of them it
caused break run now you might be
wondering you cannot connect it or
something but at least station gym or
know it was it was Costa kyungmin
talking about at least he got a
connector for the mid-course brake run
so if you use a brake thing like that
which I would recommend you to do
because it looks a lot more realistic
and can make your brake run look a
little bit less boring and bland so use
those special connectors for the brake
run and then of course a normal gentle
connector for the end of the brake run
where it goes down again now this is
actually the part where I get where it
gets really really annoying because one
thing I might tell you about this set is
that it's an uneven it's an unfinished
set basically coaster Joe was working on
this set it's working
never mind basically he was working on
this set and it looked great everyone
was happy and then he was like nope
screw the set I'm not going to work on
it anymore so everyone was sad and then
people were like I just release it so he
actually released it but it wasn't
finished yet so it's incomplete we
haven't got the right either rights or
the left's
zero zero and for example we also don't
have the gentle medium curves there's
just one of them but that just so
happens to not be in the direction that
this curve is right here so I'm going to
like as you can see it actually goes in
an entirely different connection
direction and this is the only piece
that could have somehow like done the
job in some way so in a case like these
where there's no connector I usually
just mess around with other types of
connectors for completely different in
versions or other elements that are
actually not really made for this kind
of situation but in in some situations
you can actually use them in a way that
they look kind of realistic and actually
fit the place where you want to place
them now I would recommend you to at
least place a gentle connector at the
top of that curve so that if you really
can't play
anything in the curve you can at least
in place a simple gentle connector at
the end of it now the thing that I'm
going to mess around with in this
tutorial which actually does work out in
this situation so if you ever get stuck
in a situation like this you can take
the gentle too steep connector in which
I'm going to take in a minute if I find
it that is you can take the gentle too
steep connector and place it at the very
end of the curve but not really the end
yet so it's in the middle of a square so
it's not technically the end but the
last little square piece of the curve
piece so that kind of matches it's not
like it's not a perfect match but from a
distance it looks really really little
oh god it looks really realistic and you
can't yeah
it looks decent enough for me so the
rest of the track is just simple gentle
and straight connectors as you would
usually place them and in a situation
like this where the track is kind of low
nothing special is happening I would
always keep either the two and a half
square rule or the three and half or the
three square rule and maybe even two in
some situations where there's a lot of
stress on the track but I usually don't
do that I use two and a half almost
everywhere in this track so I'd
recommend you to do that as well except
for when you've got like you can see
these gentle large curves like this one
then you need to get a gentle connector
and like that one at the very beginning
of the curve because like I said it's a
beta set and it's not really finished
yet and there's no connector piece for
the large gentle curve so you're going
to have to place a connector at the
beginning of it and a connector at the
end of it and the same counts for the
the large gentle slope curve at the
other side of this little airtime Hill
so what I usually do is place two
diagonal gentle connectors at either
side of this thing just like that and
have gentle just regular straight gentle
connectors at the bottom so while I'm
trying to figure
it's time to move on and actually go
into the corkscrews and corkscrews is
not even that's hard especially not with
that with this kind of set yeah I'll get
to explain that right now sometimes I
see people using these things for the
corkscrew
corkscrew supports now that is fine for
an arrow or maybe in some scenarios even
if a karma coaster but not for a bnm
coaster I mean for a benign coasters
there's also some simple connector
pieces in the bnm connector set right
here sometimes
nevermind basically you've got some
large corkscrew coasters pieces by the
way speaking of large cork screws I
always always use likes large quarters
in my layouts never ever use small cork
screws because in this game small cork
screws are kind of painful and small
yeah they're not really nice and not
smooth and just painful in general but I
guess that if you're building an aero
coaster for example you might want to
use them because arrows are small and
painful and not smooth but moving on
this is this has been am coaster so no
we're not going to do that we're going
to use large cork screws and use large
corkscrew to make the connector pieces
so while we're doing that yeah then you
have to take no you're not going to take
moby steel jungle yes I first want to
finish off all these things before
before I forget that I always want to
add these basic version 1 bottoms just
because they like stories but also I
want I want to add them before I start
on the real supports because if I don't
do that that might just be me by the way
but if I don't do that then I might at
some point forget to place them and
actually place the rest of the supports
and are floating connectors and that's
something which you don't want to have
but now we're going to open Moby Steel
jungle yeah and we're going to take a
bar vertical which is kind of a cool
piece because in this scenario and
actually
so it does these corkscrew connected
pieces that actually well that's that's
not good I don't have to change that
later on but these core true connected
pieces are actually pretty nice because
you can get a centerpiece and then get a
4h Center and add it to it like that
which is quite nice and you can also if
you want to do that you can also add it
like this just a little bit higher which
is actually nicer so I'm going to do
that but I'm not entirely sure what the
situation is in real life whether
they're high or low or whether it really
matters because I don't think so but
that should be good and now I just need
to replace that connector which I just
removed and oh it's still a bit too high
that's unfortunate
oh well it's not too much work so with
that out of the way
the supports are nearly finished except
for the photos I'm going to do the
footers in a standalone episode of
something stupid episode about nothing
because footers is one of the most
boring things oh and then of course
there's also flanges because they're
annoying they are really annoying
because the the thing with those things
is that if you don't add them everyone's
going to whine about it and you're going
to see it if you don't add them you're
going to be like oh no something's off
here but if you do add them nobody even
gives a [ __ ] nobody really pays
attention to those things no those those
round things with with the bolts and
stuff yeah nobody nobody pays attention
to them but you still have to add them
if you want to be a realistic person I
mean if you want to be a person who
built realistic coasters no if you want
to be a realistic person that will be
weird I feel like space of threes maybe
a bit too much new though I also guess
that's good enough now for being amps I
see many people always place crossbeams
and if you don't know what that is it's
the horizontal beam so for example many
coasters will have like these horizontal
beams to just support it a bit just like
this well PNM's don't usually do that
so forget about these things don't place
them keep everything vertical or
diagonal and it will look very PNM ish
that's one of the yeah one of the I
could call it a life hack of building
B&M coasters this is situation in which
I would have liked to use a 6h by the
way just going to try a 8h because this
is kind of mm I'm kind of in doubt about
what I should 8h does look a lot better
yeah right now I don't feel like
pointing it towards that direction so
I'm going to use this then use an 8h in
another direction over here and a
straight 8h over there which is I don't
know it just kind of looks cool I guess
yeah that looks decent you know and for
this little thing right here I always
like to take some four H's like this
just some straight things and kind of
place them like this because it looks
nice from the side and that's about it's
four that's little hill
now the helix well you can't really call
it a helix it's done this turnaround
thing elements it's kind of an annoying
thing to supports which is one of the
one of the things that I usually
struggle with because you wanna you want
to keep the yeah you want to kind of
keep the two and a half to three square
kind of rule but the only problem is
like I said it's a beta set again and
there's no there aren't
connector pieces for every part of this
curve thing so again you're going to
have to mess around with various
interesting connector pieces to see what
fits best
in this case I feel like this should
work and it does so that's great I'm not
entirely sure about this though then
that looks decent enough and I'm going
to take it straight one over here it
doesn't seem under support it's there's
a bit of a gap right here I don't feel
like there's anything I can do about
that and in this case this is going to
be a bit hard because the thing is again
I'm gonna have a gentle connector right
here but then there's a huge gap hmm you
know what I'll just I'll just move this
banked piece should be good enough yeah
that's close enough though it does seem
a bit under supported but the thing you
can immediately see right here is the
fact that you're always going to have
slightly on the supported area or over
support it because you can also add this
one piece and then you get this and then
you can remove that and place the
connector right here and then you've got
a gap here so whatever you're going to
do there is no real way to get out of
this situation without using extreme
measures like steel works and we're not
doing that so again basic procedure
right here just a gentle connector with
a basic bottom and I'm going to place
the bottom right here before I forget
about that I feel like I'm saying right
here too much sorry about that and then
we're almost finished I mean last break
run flat gentle piece should do no
nevermind
because I can count this is where it
touches the ground then I should kind of
place the connector right here that's
just a small rule of thumb that I like
to use not sure if it's really realistic
or anything but so far it's been
effective at making
decent-looking supports yeah that's what
now fits so that's great and before I
forget about that little thing I just
need to add another connector here since
there's a medium curve that's kind of
under supported now as soon as I find
the dam connected for this okay good now
all you need to do is take a few basic
bottom things connect them to the
connectors and then you're almost done
with the supports that is you just need
to connect some things to the ground so
it's not form of your steel jungle again
to connect all these things to the
ground same goes for this little brake
run thing don't worry about the brake
run right now by the way you can just
normally support it now and worry about
the brake run scenery or transfer track
if you want to do that later on you
don't really need to keep that in mind
when you're doing the supports now
support now adding the beams to these
curved things can be a bit tricky it's
add some light sometimes because they
have some weird placements like Center
and edge stuff like that now I do notice
that it's a bit under supported at this
point it does look that way
oh it's an edge piece
though again I argue it's just about
enough I would normally go for just a
few more support mama that came out
really weird just for few more supports
but the thing is if I want to try that
out I'm going to have to mess around for
a very long time and they won't all
connect perfectly I do want them to
connect in a really nice way and this
does seem somewhat acceptable
something's just going to keep it this
way
and since this is about 4h why I think
oh no it's actually 3h I might as well
just use 3h no I can't
it's a centerpiece never mind about that
centerpieces are annoying you can't do
much with it with them but you can just
forget about those so I think that's
about it yeah that's all the supports
for this go through and don't look don't
really worry about the coast of looking
under supporters or sometimes people
feel like there's a lack of Bach
supports because some coasters they have
this these sturdy box supports and the
track does look really big in comparison
to the supports but this is this is
quite normal for B and M by the way I
just noticed this beam MS have really
thin supports when you compare it to how
big the track actually is which is just
just if you didn't know this is actually
something that I don't know even though
I'm not really a coach to enthusiasts
B&M tracks are hollow so they don't
really weigh that much
so this should be about enough
supporting for this track so that's
about it for today's episode
join me tune in next time by the way for
the next episode when we're going to
have some happy fun times with flanges
and footers which is going to be great
so till then